their on-screen Sparks delighted
millions of fans but Ryan Gosling's
behind the scenes clashes with this one
co-star mean they'll likely never appear
on screen together again what do you
want it happens alarmingly often actors
end up completely clashing with one
another on set leading to rough filming
experiences and fervent promises to
never work with each other in the future
it may surprise you but for a whole host
of reasons Ryan Gosling and Rachel
McAdams are unlikely to appear in
anything else together despite their
crackling chemistry as Ali and Noah in
the classic 2004 romance The Notebook
McAdams and Gosling reportedly didn't
get along well at all on the film set
and at one point it threatened to bring
the whole movie to a halt we certainly
had
um you know intense creative
conversations but
um sorry what was the question is
Entertainment Weekly reported in 2014 as
soon as camera stopped rolling during
filming the two would argue non-stop
director Nick cassavetes told VH1 maybe
I'm not supposed to tell this story but
they were really not getting along one
day on set really not Ryan came to me
and there's 150 people standing in this
big scene and he says Nick come here
he's doing a scene with Rachel and he
says would you take her out of here and
bring in another actress to read off
camera with me I said what is says I
can't I can't do it with her I'm just
not getting anything from this
casavettes went on to explain that he
Gosling McAdams and a producer all went
into a room together to have it out the
director continued speaking of Gosling
and McAdams they started screaming and
yelling at each other I walked out and
it got better after that you know they
had it out I think Ryan respected her
for standing up for her character and
Rachel was happy to get that out in the
open the rest of the film wasn't smooth
sailing but it was smoother sailing
gossolini McAdams clashes kind of makes
sense in light of their characters the
relationship between Ali and Noah in the
notebook is often passionate to the
point of volatility as teenagers Noah
basically annoys Ali and also puts
himself in a dangerous situation until
she agrees to date him not a great or
recommended approach when they reunite
years later in adulthood they still
fight exactly as fiercely as they love
one another during the film's climactic
fight Gosling's Noah is pretty blunt
with Ali telling her well that's what we
do
we fight
you tell me when I'm being an arrogant
son of a and I tell you when
you're being a pain in the ass seems
like McAdams and Gosling had similar
feelings on set but then things got
really weird in a plot twist neither
cassavetes nor the notebook author
Nicholas Sparks could have predicted
that off-screen ire turned to real-life
love and the two ended up dating for
about two years as Gosling told the
guardian in 2007 I don't know what
happened two years later I saw her in
New York and we started getting the idea
that maybe we were wrong about each
other fans probably remember one big
moment from their relationship the
moment McAdams and Gosling won best kiss
at the 2005 MTV movie awards for the
notebook when they won the pair went to
opposite sides of the stage before
Gosling beckoned McAdams meeting her in
the middle and sweeping her into his
arms for a wildly passionate kiss the
crowd went wild and the couple managed
to create one of the most iconic awards
show appearances in recent memory in the
process apparently Gosling Bears no ill
will toward McAdams and he even bestowed
a seriously big title upon her during an
interview with GQ in 2007 saying I mean
God Bless The Notebook and introduced me
to one of the great loves of my life but
people do Rachel and Mia disservice by
assuming we were anything like the
people in that movie Rachel and my love
story is a hell of a lot more romantic
than that still that love story
ultimately ended and it feels unlikely
that they'll pair up again for another
project after all the drama